It's mentioned in surah Zar chapter
number 39 verse number 41 that we have
revealed to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him the Quran so [snorts] that
he may instruct the humankind not only
the Muslims of the Arabs but the whole
of humankind. So the glorious Quran
because it is the last and final
revelation from Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala to the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. It
was not revealed only for the Muslims or
the Arabs. It is revealed for the whole
of humanity.
The glorious Quran is a proclamation to
humanity. It is the most positive book
in the world. It's a fountain of mercy
and wisdom. It's a guide to the erring.
It's a warning to the heless. It's an
assurance to those in doubt. It's a
solace to the suffering and a hope to
those in despair. Whenever you have an
equipment, normally along with
equipment, you get an instruction
manual. And more complicated the
equipment,
the more requirement of an instruction
manual. For example, if you buy a DVD
player,
it says if you want to play the DVD,
insert the DVD and press the play
button. If you want to stop, press the
stop button. Don't immerse it in water,
it will get spoiled. Don't drop it from
a height, it will get damaged. The dos
and don'ts of that equipment, that
machine
is mentioned in an instruction manual.
If you allow me to call a human being a
machine or equipment, you'll have to
agree that the human being is the most
complicated machine on the face of this
earth.
Don't you think it requires an
instruction manual? The instruction
manual for the human beings, it is a
glorious Quran. The dos and don'ts for a
human being is mentioned in the last and
final revelation the glorious Quran.
Allah says in the Quran in surah mulk
chapter number 67 verse number two
it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good in
deeds. So this life that we are leading
in this world according to the last and
final revelation is a test. We human
beings Allah our creator says in the
Quran the last and final revelation that
this life is a test.
Allah has created death and life to test
which of you is good in deeds. What is
the purpose of our lives? Why are we
here? What are we doing? Have we thought
about it? Have we thought about it that
what are we doing in this world? What is
the purpose of our life? Allah says in
surah zarat chapter number 51 verse
number 56
that we have created the jin and the men
not but to worship me. So the main
purpose of the human beings
according to our creator is to worship
Allah subhanaa tala. The Arabic word
used in the Quran is abd. The word ibada
is used coming from the Arabic word ab
which means a slave. When we follow the
commandments of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala, it means we are doing ibada. If
we are doing the things which he has
said is compulsory, we are doing ibada.
If we abstaining from thing which is
haram and prohibited, we are doing
ibada. So when we follow the
commandments of Allah subhana wa ta'ala,
when we pray, we are doing ibada. When
we give zakat, we are doing ibada. When
we fast, we are doing ibada. When we
don't have alcohol, we are doing ibada.
When we don't gamble, we are doing
ibada. When we don't tell lies, we are
doing ibada. So ibada means following
the commandments of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala
as true servants of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala and the cornerstone
of the Islamic faith and of the Quran